what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i'm going
to be reacting to women
are now showing their insights on
youtube don't believe me
watch this video the curiosity is just
killing me so i'm going to react to the
video today
before i start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel as you guys
know i'm trying to hit 20 000
subscribers that is a huge goal for the
channel
and each and every one of you helps
while you're at it ring that
notification
bell that way you're going to be
notified of my daily videos
okay
i've never seen this guy before
conversation today
you're looking at the title of the video
you're looking at the thumbnail video
and you're probably like
what are you talking about mtr
you're making no sense i'm gonna explain
and you will be surprised i
wholeheartedly promise you
that you will i am a youtuber and i
didn't even know that this was
a thing the reason why i want to bring
up this particular topic is
what i have started to learn is that
nothing is like in life is fair
i'm saying when i say started to learn
i'm being facetious when i say that
oftentimes some of the talking points on
the channel are
focused in on how women have easier
lives than men
and i contest that i think that in
totality
they do i think men from a a life
perspective
have it more difficult but i think from
a relationship perspective
women actually have it more difficult
okay
but from a life from a living from the
allowances from the privileges
i think women's life are a little bit
easier they have a little bit more
options a little bit more things that
are available to them and they get
additional props up from
society i would agree with everything he
said
pretty much at large shout out to the
young lady that went down to atlanta
i think men are an advantage when it
comes to dating because they have time
they have time to get better at dating
they have time to make more money and
they have time
to like
i don't know that's what i would say
they have time like they have time to
make mistakes they can invest in the
wrong
woman and still like come back from that
or a lot of women that doesn't
happen for anna got stuck down there
because she didn't go down there with
enough money and then set up a gofundme
page and all these simps were just
donating to her
that's part of my point anyway but i
agree with female female privilege is
real that's a real thing
i was scrolling through my instagram let
me just pop that down in there
make sure y'all follow me at mediocre
tutorials and reviews there's a link
directly to my instagram
down in the description box down below
hello and good evening mtr
me and my boyfriend absolutely love your
channel well thank you i appreciate the
love
it is not many but some women such as
myself are waking up
so please keep up the hard work i wanted
to ask
if you could do a video about the naked
yoga fad
that is going on in the youtube spaces
i thought it was a joke but women are
literally naked on camera
doing yoga with all of their innards
showing on youtube
would love to hear your perspective
on this okay now you'll see
down in there i'm not gonna show the
screenshot well actually let me see can
i show any of the screenshot
but you'll see down in there it looks
like youtube and they have naked yoga
okay in the search bar so
i took a look at this and the first
thing i said to myself is no
no there's no way that they're allowing
full nudity
on the youtube i'm not about it
i'm about to youtube this on my phone
and see if that's
true i had to check it out for
to join myself get somewhere
where you can get all those clothes off
grab some yoga tools
let's get started
yep
those are the viscous innards i know
what they look like from anywhere
okay i feel weird
i couldn't find it on my
i'm gonna phone it right here okay my
paws are right here
and i watched for educational purposes i
watched
a little bit more of this she's
definitely doing yoga
but the mammary glands and the viscous
innards are everywhere
as what you cannot see right now because
i don't want my channel to get popped so
i will block this out i was perplexed i
was confused and i was befuddled i i had
not known that this was actually a thing
i went down a linked trail
and i found a whole bunch of other
content
publicly available on youtube of women
completely naked just doing things and
i'm like
when did this happen now immediately
let me get this off the screen because i
feel like it's devaluing what it is that
i'm saying
immediately i said to myself this isn't
fair
okay how do i have a platform where i
have to create
words to overstep the filtering system
on youtube so
but okay you have to think about that's
not a long-term solution like girls can
do that
until they're what 35 maybe 40.
if you look like jlo 50 i guess if you
look like jlo you could do it for a
lifetime but in general
the majority of women are not going to
be able to do that long term
i do not get banned shadow banned
community strike line strikes and all of
this stuff like that
how is it that my speech
right through controversial issues is
monitored it needs to be filtered [ __ ] i
create
new words on the channel viscosity
viscous energy so that
the content filtering whatever youtube
does doesn't
get me hemmed up and the channel popped
how is it that i can't speak freely
but that there's channels of naked
people
on youtube where kids visit so i did
some investigation
here's what i found out now for those
that don't know youtube
actually has a community guidelines i'm
so glad he looked up community
guidelines so i don't have to
page and for all of you guys that are
budding youtubers i suggest
that you study this page so you can
understand
what is within the limits of
youtube platform and i'm saying to
myself
i'm not gonna lie i don't see myself
doing that if there's legit pages by the
way
that video i just clicked on had 50 000
views i saw another yoga video
that had five million views that was
uploaded months ago
okay so these are creators that are
creating a buzz getting subscribers
with nudity as well right and even in
that video i just looked at as well
she was touching the viscosity and all
types of stuff like it was a part of the
of the yoga practice and i'm like yo
this is
this is concerning okay i'm a concerned
person all right so there is uh this
page so let's take a look at this one
nudity and sexual content all right
now i think that this is important to go
over because i was just so confused but
walk with me here real quick
all right let's let's watch
[Music]
true or false nudity is never allowed on
youtube
what do you think true now the answer is
false sexually explicit content like
pornography
isn't allowed we actually allow nudity
when the primary purpose is educational
documentary scientific what
and if there's no nudity but minimal
clothing meant only to be sexually
provocative
it'll likely be age restricted let's
take a look at other examples
a creator uploads a video about the
greatest works of art in history
which contains nude artwork in another
video a creator uploads a compilation of
hacked photos and clips
that contain nude celebrities do either
of these videos
violate our community guidelines
yes the second video violates the sex
and nudity policy
okay let me pause it right there so what
do we just learn
okay if it's for educational purposes
if it's not for gratification right if
it's for art
artistic reasons some of the things that
that that was said in there
then apparently it was what aloud
okay this is fascinating to me i don't
know when they instituted this
okay but this is apparently a thing on
youtube right now why is this important
so i i'm not going to do this but
hypothetically if i
taught manosphere content naked
that would be allowed well for all of
the parents out there i think that it is
extremely important now before
the younger person in your life asked to
see your phone or your tablet to go up
on youtube and watch videos that you are
age restrict restricting
and age-gating the profiles that they
are using
there's a youtube kids and as well as
there's just the youtube application but
on the youtube application
you have to use profiles that are age
restricted or they might stumble across
nudity content just had a conversation
with sister shahadzad ali and one of the
things that she talked about when i
asked her about
child rearing that we need to do is to
guard young eyes from sexually explicit
content but also and mark my words
this will be the new game okay
this will be the new avenue because
nudity now can be hidden behind the
guise
of educational content i mean just think
about it for a quick second let's say
that you are a budding
sex worker right but no one really knows
you
you don't really have a presence at all
you try to get up on our only fans
but you have to deal with those that
have only fan accounts but they're also
influencers in the market right now when
only fans you know some of you
think that it's easy to become a content
creator and only fans is not easy
because it's incredibly saturated right
now right because there's a million
girls doing it but this is
insane i cannot believe this is a
problem
that came with the internet is that
like children are being exposed to
things
much earlier and i don't know about you
but
being like
growing up in a generation before this
was all like widespread like by the time
i got
a phone that like had internet on it it
was like high school
so i really wasn't exposed to a lot of
this stuff but even on like tick tock
and stuff you see like half naked girls
that are underage a lot of the times
like
dancing super provocatively and that's
totally okay
but i ca i cannot believe they can do
like naked yoga
competition no pun intended but mark my
words this will be the new game
okay create a youtube channel say it's
for educational purposes only
and show your guts you'll gain
subscribers you'll gain a following
and then you'll do like what the vast
video did and you'll link your website
down in the youtube description so then
people can
get the behind the scenes content up
at their website absolutely fascinating
so what these content creators do is
that in the beginning of the videos they
say something like this this video
doesn't in any way support or encourage
any sexual behavior or sexual
gratification
or graphic sexual content this video is
meant for educational
doc documentary documentary purposes
only don't watch if you are below 18
and the content is in fact age
restricted and there is
a lot of nudity in this and you'll see
right here
3 million views at the end
of the day you can't hate the player you
gotta just hate the game
i really wanted to talk about this for
two reasons the first one is that
no one over here in this sector of
youtube is actually talking about this
um i haven't seen anyone mention
anything of
this naked yoga or naked i saw a naked
newscaster show i saw a whole bunch of
nakedness naked that
um that these content creators are
utilizing sexuality in order to
monetize the content that they're at
they're providing
another reason was really to just
demonstrate how
men and women are judged by two
different
playing fields okay having the ability
to put sexually explicit content up and
then call it for educational
purposes all right and i just watched
one not too long ago it was called
it was a naked yoga one and literally
she was bent over
guts poking out the camera the entire
time and
to be able to get on a platform like
this one of which
censors me for the type of things that i
say
regarding the culture regarding gender
regarding all these different things and
you know we could talk about all of
the silencing that has gone on in
youtube for so goddamn long but then to
also
allow showing your guts for educational
purposes
with links down in the description box
down below below to go follow them
on their other platforms so that they
can continue to monetize it because they
can't monetize it on youtube
i just that's crazy that that's allowed
on youtube
it's one thing if it's like an only fans
or like a website designed for that but
that's
that's really wild to me i think is a
bit you know
unfair you know calling a spade a spade
out here at the end of the day
if we cannot allow complete utter
freedom of speech then why are we
allowing complete and utter nudity could
this also be
i agree with him like if they're
censoring his
stuff i mean i don't know what he gets
taken down
i'm assuming it's just things that he
disagrees with about the culture that
maybe
youtube disagrees with or like a lot of
people disagree with maybe report the
video
but if you're gonna allow people doing
naked yoga that's really that really
isn't fair i agree
male naked yoga sure yeah but if you
look at all the videos there's no
dudes up here right there's no dudes
it's if you put in naked yoga and you
take a look
it's nothing but women completely and
utterly
it's completely and utterly so it's
almost as if
they found a way to get by the system
they found a way to you know get on here
and use the number two search engine
uh in the world in order to uh make
money and profit off of it and at the
end of the day
again i i'm not hating on it it just it
just is what it
is i just felt the need to be able to
talk about it in the best way that i
could
to let you guys all know what the future
game will be i think it's you know
okay um so my thoughts i'm i just ended
it
i get the point my thoughts is it's
extremely inappropriate
for them to be having naked people on
youtube i think that's really just
common sense so
the fact that youtube's allowing this is
like my
like mind-blowing to me because
like that's just crazy so um
if the people at youtube see this that's
actually very disrespectful and it's not
sorry disrespectful is the wrong word
it's very um inappropriate
and if it was up to me like i wouldn't
think that would be allowed
but let me know in the comments if you
agree or you disagree
let me know um what
you feel like would be fair for youtube
and do not forget to subscribe to the
channel
and ring that notification bell